and please bear with us for a moment
while we begin our live stream
ugh
one moment
there we go
oh
all right
our linkedin live stream has begun we're
also on youtube live
and welcome to our career webinar
uh recruitment trends that are shaping
professional hiring in 2021
uh presented with sarbajit malik the
co-founder
and cbo of uh organization for
insta hire and we're
glad to have him back
um just a note about the webex controls
of questions for star widget should be
put into the q
a box put them in the q a box we'll be
able to log
them and ask him the questions in the q
a
portion of the presentation at the end
can put information into the chat box
make sure you address it to all
panelists otherwise we will not
necessarily
see it and
we're also going to be doing a few polls
today
so the first one
very simple two questions how much
experience do you have
you should see if you're on webex you
should see a
polling widget the second question is
something we've been asking people
during the pandemic
how you're adjusting to this
ongoing situation how you're feeling
today
and we'll keep the pull open for about
another 15 seconds
if you're watching live streaming feel
free to put answers in the comments
all right and
here are our poll results
we have an experienced audience today
although we have people across all
experience levels the largest contingent
are people
from the greater than 10 years
and fortunately over 90 percent of you
said that you're feeling
at least in the middle if not well today
and
for the rest of you we hope that this
presentation will give you information
that'll help improve your outlook so
with that i am going to introduce
sar bridget hey hi guys
um he's responsible for anything
required to make customers happy as the
chief business officer of organization
over at insta hire he's a previous
company founder he founded trip hippie
which is a
adventure travel service
and he is
engineering alumnus of nit durgapur and
an mba from nti niti
i'm sorry so i'm going to
let him introduce
insta hire and welcome sarvajic
so this webinar we will be discussing on
the future trends
which is 2021 and 2018 and the future
with what polls
so before we do that uh so i am the
co-founder of
instagram and what we do is
very simple we help companies
to get great talent like you guys but
10x more accurately and 10x in less time
so that everyone has a win-win situation
okay what do you mean by accuracy is
basically
you will not receive spam emails or
like calls which will be annoying you
will receive job offers
or interview calls which are relevant to
you
so that is what we mean in an actual
working by
accuracy or relevancy okay so we have uh
we have seen that there are a lot of
changes technological changes happening
throughout
but in this recruitment side we have
seen that not much has changed
and it we use the initial techniques
which are there
like only in data research
we thought me and adapter to change
everything
and flip the model so we built uh
the technology which helps companies
to mimic a human recruiter understand
the candidate better and then to start
talking or communicating with the
candidate so that the conversion of a
candidate is very very fast
okay so we have made different models to
it
uh this is a basic outline of how we
operate
we have our own property algorithm which
is instant match
which considers everything so we i will
go through what do you what do i mean by
everything
okay so everything will mean like what
your interests are
or whether you can't be working okay how
is your career progression going on then
what are the
things you like or dislike or what type
of companies do you want to
like be in what is your dream job so we
understand all these data points
and then uh we send you the
best jobs which are there in the market
basically what we're trying to do is
make the world a better place by giving
jobs to
mostly all the candidates so that uh
these candidates can get the best of
both the worlds so they spend less time
get more job offers
and similarly they have better time to
prepare
okay so uh traditional problems which
are
existing in uh the candidates are
uh like basically there are high number
of calls for
basically legal event jobs which are not
uh your cup of tea
okay but you simply get this calls or
you get
emails which are like actually it is not
even relevant to your profile
and or you do not get any interview
calls so these are the three problems
which we have seen in the candidate and
we have solved it
so what makes us uh stand uh like
as one of the pioneers of this and we
have very very large companies using our
product
okay so mostly all the tech companies
which you
like cooperating and know of and
these are all our clients and we do this
things like instant talent pipeline we
have very high intent candidates
engagement ratio
is much higher so yeah do try out and
let me know your feedback on this
so yeah like you can go to the next
slide
yeah so this is uh our capabilities
which
powers like 10 000 plus enterprises we
worked with
and so this is what inside stands for
and uh
in the next slide we will see the
companies which we worked with
which are like one of the largest
companies in the world
which are using our product okay so if
you see amazon walmart opel
uh jpmc
so all the large companies in the world
use our product for the
hiring and we have been able to change a
lot of uh
careers and we have been able to bring
science in the faces of a lot of
candidates as we go about
but it has been an exciting journey and
today i will share you the insights
of what is the next five years ago but
next three years look in the recruitment
trends will be
taking up
so that concludes the introductory
slides um so
let's start the conversation um i'm
gonna
run the first poll just to
get an impression from the audience and
here to queue it up
doing that i'm gonna see if i can fix
the live stream
and here are the poll results yeah so
it was quite distributed i guess i have
too many calls for 11 from the 17th
no interview called 38 person know
follow-up response 27-percent
so you see that these are majorly the
problems
there are no interview process being the
larger
of the port so
a very very interesting study which we
did
as uh as we as we start of the
recruitment trends we see that
why there are no interview calls see if
you understand clearly there are a lot
of jobs
and yes there are a lot of candidates
but why are these candidates getting
this right set of jobs
or these jobs person this is because
there is a
huge gap in communication now
if i give you uh like say 10 000
candidates
to operate from and i tell you that okay
hire me for
five candidates you will start emailing
all of them but you do not know which
candidate is actually looking
up for a job or is actually the
uh guys who are relevant for your job
postings
right so this is the problem then you
end up with 10
000 emails in your inbox and you do not
process any
and what happens is these guys they do
not get the interview so this is the
larger problem which we have seen right
so no follow-up responses basically same
the recruiters are inundated with
thousands of emails emails follow-up
emails all this kind of means but
they are not reaching out to the right
set of candidates
that is not the fault of either parties
that is the part of
the communication channel which is
non-existent which marks non-existent
and in india also we operate out of
india in india also we have seen this
problem coming in
like we will get thousands of calls or
maybe no calls at all
and either way this is not helpful for
the candidate so yes
so yeah i can get in i'm sorry sorry how
are you addressing those problems
uh from instagram what
differentiates the the platform so that
people experience fewer of these
frustrations
so uh supposedly if you are a human
recruiter
and you have to operate on a database
set suppose i will tell you to hire a
software engineer
and you will find you you work for a
company suppose say amazon
and you want to have people from
e-commerce companies to work for you for
a software engineer
example okay most of the companies are
still agnostic so that is not a problem
but still
suppose you want to have people from
flipkart or mensa
or any other kind of company sharing
e-commerce operating unicorns
so this is a very clear mandate so you
want people who have
been working in product companies and
better will be people who are from
e-commerce or similar kind of
intellect company background but if i
give you a ten thousand resume
and can you go higher from that you what
you will do you you cannot find out this
kind of candidates first of all you have
to go through each and every day
that people won't do and people will
just start mass emailing them
secondly what you will also do is
basically
you your emails will not be personalized
it will be basically your same email
which will be copy paste
or you will send a mark email to all in
both of these cases
the candidate sees you okay so i have
received this email
but this email is kind of looking like a
scanning name
okay i have received this email which is
absolutely not
relevant to me i have done java in five
years back
now i am doing i am aware okay
so if it's not like it's not relevant
right
so you might have got to some keyword
search and send an email
but they will not reply that or if they
reply that
you might not answer because you will
get thousands of replies
that is the most important so the
communication channel is completely
broken
you do not know so candidates before us
was only a
kind of a database in the database name
phone number email id resume that's it
the candidate has different sets of it
like the candidates are human being
right they will have preferences
they want to work in internet companies
we want to work in certain type of
enterprises or startups or very high
growth
mid-level companies okay they might be a
very good coder but
they are very actively putting effort
to learn something and they want to do a
job in that space because it's the new
upcoming space they need or they have
grown a new interest yet okay supposedly
they might not be from the best
iv ivy league colleges they might be
from tier two tier three colleges
but they are highly skilled how do you
get
to know that they are highly skilled
they will not know because we need to
talk to only the skills and the resume
which doesn't speak about anything about
you being highly skilled
but if you see their github profile or
their
achievements or their career goals you
will find out okay this guy
might be very very useful for me
so these are the things which companies
generally
miss because they use those old
traditional tools which are there in
india
so they completely miss this kind of uh
very very
very very relevant data which might
make or break your company okay what
they do is they
simply send a link to thousands of
people
then they pray that they will come back
but they will receive a certain amount
of
applications then they start manually
sorting it
then this um like 80 percent is rejected
20
they go through but with this if you see
you are wasting a lot of time okay a
very good candidate
we have seen on instagram and in general
also our instagram
poll very good candidate will be there
in the market for 10 to 12 days maximum
and a very very good candidate will be
like say six to seven days in the market
there will be job before that they will
be getting thousands of offers
and this from some of us they might have
like 10 to 15 very very good offers
they might select one of them okay that
depends on the profile and skills
whatever
but this but if you are wasting like 15
days to sort out candidates and then you
communicate with them most of these guys
are gone from your
pool which is non-existent like and the
rest of these guys
might be in the later stages of their
interviews or might
then not start a new conversation
because they have already
staged the stage four so that way the
intuitive business of a lot of
candidates
because of the time to hire which is a
metric which is very very useful in
recruiting is very very high okay
so now what the future holds is
basically using technology
to understand uh the kind of
candidates you are best suited for
the company is best suited for right so
this is the technology which we have
built and it has been working
at scale uh for us uh so
that way we have uh done a
job where we have seen candidates
applying
recruiters replying and everything is
going smooth
so this is how we have changed the
entire model
on its own we do have a question
from the chat we have two questions that
i'd like to
just address real quick one is um
is insta hire limited to india
so instagram is not limited to india
instagram
has been operating out of india and yes
we do not have
uh presence in u.s but u.s companies
come
to india or use companies when they hire
remote they use our
platform so yes we have indian
candidates
on instagram but uh foreign companies
also like example like
a lot of them like uber and uh
which are very very popular as of now
and then there is in the u.s like
euro and thousands other companies that
you see in the slide they
all uh hired from our
candidate pool and these guys are all
operating out of uh
india or in the u.s but remotely higher
so this part is that
we do not have u.s based or outside
india based on
um and the other question is um
you talk about demonstrating um
skills things like github for software
people
what are some what are some of the
skills demonstration tools you can use
in other
domains like what would a how would a
project manager
show off a portfolio how would the
digital marketers go off a portfolio
that type of thing
so there are different kind of tools
which these guys use like a designer
will throw up the portfolio
and advance of your result if
a project manager can show off the
portfolio basically
by giving up the like what kind of
projects they have executed
and that will also be recorded so uh
the beauty of technologies is basically
it can operate at scale
and it can work like a human if given
sufficient data to understand what kind
of
candidates these are okay suppose you
will be hiring for a project manager and
you want
for a solar project and you want guys
who have worked in energy sector
and not in the paint sector or chemical
sector and these guys should work
in certain kind of solar projects or
basically renewable energy projects
how will you get that because you will
be seeing like 10 000 candidates of
one lakh candidates who are working
suppose the energy sector but
you cannot differentiate their working
renewables or this kind of facts
so this is how you get kind of uh
candidates which we sorted by the
algorithm which you show you so this is
the candidate which are best to get for
your company
suppose your company suppose you are
having for amazon because your company
is a startup which
like 30 people start up okay and you're
here
so these two for the same job we will
show you two
separate set of candidates which these
candidates will be relevant for you plus
they have
work experience in startup plus they are
looking for startup jobs
versus the companies like amazon like
paypal or walmart they're hiring for
people who might have a little bit of
experience in the enterprise segment
or a little bit of experience in the
architecture forbidding large companies
so that is how we differentiate so
everything is sorted uh and
shown up to the recruiter and this
recruiters
reach out we like tell the recruiters
to do our products also to our teams
to reach out to this candidate
i'm going to run another poll because
this will lead us into another
subject for discussion um
and i want the button to appear
so this poll is for the audience um
how do you research
the company that you want to work for
and i'll put up the uh
slide just so people can see it from the
uh
live link hold on a moment
application
so do you use the website do you use
their linkedin page
do you use the job description i know
there are other
tools as well
i will put up the poll results
so most yeah most people you can company
website so
what would you what would you advise a
job seeker in terms of
number one how important is it to do
that research into the companies that
you're
applying to and number two what are the
kinds of
tools you would advise them to look at
using
so fundamentally speaking uh this is the
most important research which the
candidates could do what is the type of
company which they are applying for
so normally the candidates help us to
apply to most of the jobs and then when
they get a call they look into the
companies
okay which they have replied that that
is also okay yeah
so things like you should look into
what is the company like so first thing
is the most important thing is
uh who will be your manager
right how's the work culture second is
the technology or maybe your work
or what is you you will be selling or
what you will be building
this kind of thing but there are three
verticals which you can do
the first thing culture is the most
important thing
to understand the culture yes you can
use
uh like brand pages of different like
job posting websites like
instagram as a friend page you can look
into the culture they will tell
you they will have photographs of their
birthday and then
second thing is basically you have to
know uh
basically the people who you will be
working with or
your manager or your subordinates
okay knowing them will help you to
understand what is the
culture internally in your team right
third thing is the job description what
is the job is given do not take a job
which
doesn't really reflect your capabilities
we take that and we are frustrated after
three months
we need that that is basically a
lossless situation for both of us
because i do
i have to find it again i cannot put it
up on linkedin i cannot put it up on my
resume
like job sites because people will ask
why do you leave in three months or two
months
okay and it also creates a impression
that
this guy is not stable of this this this
guy is not
sticky to a company that is one
major problem which we have seen and
this leads to career gaps
career gaps are not that important but
in certain companies you might face
so do not do that first second thing
is when you when you uh understand kind
of
what is the job description what exactly
does it mean
what will you be doing what problem are
you solving
what is the impact of that problem you
should have clear answers to that
and this will also be asked in your
interview like what what do you think
your
job what do you think our company does
and you have to be very clear
else you would not be selected okay so
certain companies are very very timidly
and very very
very very strict on what the brand
stands for
and that is known as the power of the
employer brand
so you have to understand what the brand
stands for
that is the most important thing because
you will be working with this company
with these guys with your team for say
five years six years ten years
unlike one or two years whatever you
will be working you will be spending
time with them
so you better understand what the
culture is is it actually suiting you
okay are is the company progressing
okay you can see different kind of like
if startups
you can see you can see different type
of views
like how how are the founders
have they have prior experience and if
you are
joining a really small setup of company
you should expect that it will be
scrappy there will not be defined
processes
because they are just building the
company if you are joining a large
enterprise
you should be aware that this is uh
an actual brand and there are some teams
and sub categories to that
so you should focus on the sub category
or
whatever you are joining which verticals
you are joining and how is the particle
going to affect you so if you see this
is a learning experience
you will learn to work okay and then
you have to have this learning expo like
exposure
to you right if you do not have the
exposure uh
like there will be issues like we will
get
kind of even even straight away like you
will see that
uh like ten dollars i am getting more
than that and then
i see a lot of candidates so we have
done a poll
on the kind of uh candidates when they
knew that they say that we want
more exposure we want better
opportunities
so if you're working in a company for
like one year two years three or four
years
you should have more exposure right so
if you're not getting it that might not
be right for you
so you have to first identify
one of the questions is basically i get
a lot of people asking me
how can i see uh the profile being seen
by
recruiting companies okay that is a very
very interesting question
how your profile will get seen by uh
recruiting company
recruiting companies basically they're
dividing two segments
the first is the companies and the
second is the
recruiting consulting firms in either of
these cases
right now it's basically still over
knowledge
okay so if you have skills in a certain
department
in a certain segment and uh and the
other guy doesn't have skill
they will always play for a guy with
skill because
if you see this one one and a half year
of pandemic and
things people stuck in their homes and
majorly using their mobile phones or
their laptop to connect
okay what they do is uh they will have a
very high digital adoption so when you
have a very high digital adoption
your profiles should like you will have
to have a certain type of skill set
to attract more people okay so this more
people might be marketing should have
hands-on experience in marketing okay
this this will attract more people so
like we might be very very good at seo
you will have a very very high
uh like acceptance rate in many
companies okay
versus a guy who has knowledge of seo
but
they do not have hands-on so that is one
of the most important things and you
should also highlight that i have
hands-on experience i have built this
website and this is what
they it does or this is the impact so
when
as a recruiter suppose you are a
recruiter who will you recruit
you want to build a company and you want
people
to like the smartest people out there so
that you can tell them
see i want to go from 1 million users to
10 million
can you do that they will say yes and
then you will like onboard them you will
not micromanage people right
so this is uh how you like
have to show your profile skills is what
you have to show
and how you have developed these things
where you have applied these skills
and what you can do for that company
that is one
uh most important aspect and you should
focus on that
that leads into an interesting question
for the audience
um because you know
as you as as you just said it's
important to show off your skills
and the skills that you actually have
but the skills need to be relevant
to the particular customer or
customer particular job that you're
applying for the company
and the and the position that you're
applying for so
um here's a question for the audience
do you customize your resume for every
job that you apply to
give people about 30 seconds to respond
to that
interesting question let's see what
and i think since it's a simple question
i'm just going to um
close off the poll in about another five
seconds here
and
21 of the people said no so about 80
percent of the people said
they do always or sometimes
yeah so i get that this yes the 38
most of them will be mbas so this is a
common practice with uh business grads
to do that customize
for each of them so this is how you put
some extra effort in your cv
and suppose you are like like
putting a resume for a finance job so
you will highlight your financial skills
versus you put operation for a marketing
job you will hired at your marketing
experience
but as you get experience you will have
like
like you will have maybe two skills like
one is marketing and one is maybe
or maybe you will be having marketing uh
in in different aspects like honest
content marketing
maybe one is seo or maybe in product
marketing
or kind of content market so this is
basically
how they highlight it so it's it's not
very uh
difficult to do that but yes you can do
that because some certain companies look
for
very very particular sets to be in
candidates so that is why people do that
there is no harm in doing that but yes
you have to justify it
uh also when when asked about what what
you have done to
your proficiency levels will be
justified
so you're basically saying that
um it's not necessarily the best
practice to do the
um customization of the resume to each
role is that
no matter what best practice it's it's
basically done uh why because
see some people do multiple things
like in a company they wear multiple ads
so they might also have like they have
done sales
also after doing sales they have gone to
maybe operations
after doing operations they have learned
about the product and they have gone to
product operations
so they can use this kind of experience
because they have like
uh various experience sets like two
years of these two years of that and
fields of that
and now they want to go back okay so
have success experience
i want to go back in two seats so they
will make a regimen which is more
inclined towards sales versus products
yeah that makes sense um
so in terms of
how the company sees you um
and working with with insta hire which
creates a
persona within your system for the
candidate
is the resume become less
important after it's after the candidate
has inputted into the insahir system
in terms of you know now that all the
information's in there i don't need this
one-page document anymore or is that
still a tool that they're going to need
going forward to present when they're
interviewing
so uh when the candidate comes onto
instagram
and then the first so before that
let me like bifurcate the steps okay so
the first
steps the screening steps which are uh
there are different companies who follow
this but there's a general pattern is
they will see the candidate and they
might do a small phone call with them
to understand the aspirations and what
the company is doing and
receive
that this candidate is relevant for me
as it is shown on
my dashboard my instagram dashboard and
they will start
calling up this family secondly uh where
the candidate goes to
the second part is the screening part
okay uh the screen part is this when you
send
assignments so now this assignment
sending
is done by the team which is hiring not
the recruiter
so i am hiring for a software engineer
role for my java team
versus the python team so the java team
will send the assignment
when the assignment comes in and they
will assist the assignment
the ones who have cleared the assignment
will be given interviews there will be
interview
the first and the last stages are the
ones who are
most important for the resume so they
will
be seeking their resume and they will be
asking direct questions
so suppose you have done a project what
was the project about what was the
problem you're solving
so can we should be very very careful
about
how they define that project in the
resume it's you know that you have
like implemented a suppose a full
project okay suppose you have
implemented everything end to end we
should know the problems which
came in suppose in the seventh day or
the tenth day and how did you solve it
because the other right might know
because b or t might have implemented
the problem
right so you should know end to end of
everything which you have done
and it's very very important to know the
impact
of that okay we have seen candidates and
we have done various schools and
companies also
companies tell us that this guy has
skills but the problem
that ufc has done they are not aware
what is the impact
on the company so you should have a
little bit of a sense to understand
what is the impact of your work so that
you can project yourself
better and you should always project
yourself that i am a valuable addition
to you
we did an interesting webinar
about a week and a half ago um
which looked at problem solving in
business
and one of the principles that the
speaker
introduced was there are three functions
in a business three types of functions
in a business
one is the function are functions that
create value the value-added functions
that
produce the value that customers pay for
then there
are necessary support functions
so essential support doesn't create
value necessary
like the accounting department in a
company you have
to have it but it isn't directly
creating value
the third function
type of function in the company is
what's called waste because
these are things that companies do
that cost them money people get paid to
do them
and hours are expended but they don't
actually
produce anything for the company just
the cost and so
the purpose of that webinar was to
address you know how do
how do you solve problems that eliminate
the waste
but for the purpose of today's
discussion
um what you just said about showing
yourself as a valuable employee is that
you want to make sure that people
perceive
your experience shows that you're either
a value-added person
or you're a very very effective person
in a
an essential support function so
one thing you don't want to do is be
seen as well
okay that's interesting but it didn't
create any value for the company so
yes why were you there so so
one of the like what has changed in the
recruitment segment is
companies are going more okay so because
of this
they're going anymore and the biggest
advantage of remote is
you are exposed to a lot many
geographies that
you have before so i was hiring suppose
i
suppose i'm based on delhi and i will
hire for people only from delhi region
who can work in my office
but right now if i'm remote i can hire
from all parts of india
or even abroad so what it does it
basically
creates a lot of more avenues for me to
hire a candidate
so that competition has gone up even the
jobs have
been open to other candidates in other
segments
secondly what we have seen that
companies when they grow and
like when people grow like they grow
forex five eggs in a year
okay and they double every three months
four months
so what they need is people who are
self-motivated
so that is the most important skill
which we have seen in companies
like they assess the skill for cultural
fit culture
doesn't mean that if this guy is like
will fit our company or not
the cultural feat is actually what means
is
if if suppose a company is there and it
has an energy pool
suppose i have an energy other people
have energy food
so suppose it is like 100 my energy pool
is
i have 100 people everyone has one okay
now if i include a person who is double
that energy
like two so every one of the community
the energy
pool increases so level of motivation
increases
people will follow this kind of
motivation it's very infectious
and people will also try to make up like
they will they will just
make targets and goals which are more
audacious than that
before this guy has jumped or before
this bunch of guys have jumped
versus there is a another set of people
who are energy suckers
which i mean like a sink so they will
reduce energy of the
crew that will demotivate a lot of
people and then they might leave your
organization
because of this thing people always look
for people who
can increase the overall energy of that
group that is the most important skill
which we have
why because people are stuck at their
homes most of them are working remotely
or they are doing hybrid work
so they need people who can give them
okay so what
what new we can do today okay and they
are looking forward so that
the human interaction is minimum so
there should be motivation
in the team the high energy means so
that everyone gets lifted up
that is one most important skill which
we have seen during this pandemic come
up as
uh basically to increase the energy over
the energy of the group
or the team yeah
that makes sense in the sense people
tend to look around them and and see
what the norm
you know what the culture says what the
norms
say for behavior if they see people
around them who are
as you say low energy low interest motor
motivation
they get the idea that that's the way
that they should behave exactly where
when you see people around you who are
striving working hard
um setting higher goals um
you get this sense of healthy
competition
that you want to be like them and you
don't want to be left behind by them so
that's that that's really as you say a
very important
quality so we can give motivation let's
uh take another quick poll here
and um see if
current slide um i'll share this
and we're looking at what is the
motivation that drives somebody to look
for a new job
in today's environment not necessarily
that you're all
in the audience looking for a new job
today but
if you're looking for a new job or if
you if you were considering that
um in today's environment in the world
we live in right now
which factors
are the most important
and i think we've set this up so you
have to pick one
and so let's
see if we can find the result here
it's a fairly even fairly even
distribution but better learning
opportunities are the main motivator
which is
you know it's it's not surprising
for anybody who's i think involved in um
recruitment hiring even education like
like the people here at simply learn um
the most i think the the popular idea is
that well
people want to find a better title or
they want to find a bigger salary but
um curiosity and the need to
you know learn more and improve you know
become a
better expert in your field it's always
a
really important factor
yeah yeah we have seen this kind of we
have done
certain surveys and polls we have done
two and we have
taught like with companies like amazon
walmart
some of the reverse and like largest
companies in the world which
aren't reporting for my platform
so at instagram we have seen this poll
going to
like do you mean specialists are the
unique
people which have what we call right and
nowadays like the
personality what is the key personality
is uh it's like
t which is the alphabet this
this guy might have three to four skills
okay and this guy will have
ample knowledge of three to four skills
but in one of the skills
or in couple of skills which i will be
very very deep
okay so what it does is you can
assign this person multiple jobs
okay and they will understand this kind
of job
okay all these jobs but they might not
be very good at it but they will
understand
and they might do the job but if
you promote them like if you make them a
manager
suppose i i suppose you have a manager
who has like very good sales skills
but this guy is also very good in
support customer support
now and may be also very good in legal
matters
okay like legal agreements and all this
like signing up of agreements and
like getting legal documents okay so
these three skills are there
this guy is very good in sales so we
will definitely do sales
but if the sales guy and the other guys
coming he
like helped me with the legal matter
also i can help
even if someone comes with like this the
problem with the support
if they can also help and if you this
kind of segment of people they are
getting promoted
very fast because if i promote this kind
of
person this guy will actually lead a
team of sales
but the guy has a very good idea of the
support systems
which works and they can also help how
sales can help the support how sales can
ease the
legal processes also so i have a
person who can actually contribute in
three departments
the first department the sales
department is very very good but the
other department also is suffering
okay this is the key personality which
is getting a lot of
traction in today's world and uh
it's not that i am only good at this i
will do that but
if you see like i i it like most of the
guys
here might have read the book how google
works
okay so in this very very interesting
example is that
uh one day the founder of google
was searching something on on google
people like 10 15 years back
after after a search uh when he
he did research and then there were
irrelevant results coming in
okay and he was very very annoying what
he did is basically he did not
ask the search team he just took a
printout
and he marked the search results in the
net
and he told that this sucks and he put
in all the
kitchen which they have the patriot on
the system
now two engineers two three engineers
came in that evening
friday to have some coffee and they saw
the results
okay they saw the look at this and they
went to it
and everyone went home this was weekend
everyone went home
friday monday morning the founder
receives an email that this is the
problem which we had
this is the solution which we did and
this is how we could have solved it
so this marked the entry of google
search which was very very like
very advanced compared like three days
back
and this guy most of the people who are
in the technology
might know this guy's name is jd who is
also one of the very very proficient
computer engineers and
he was the guy who was not into the
search team
okay he was working in something else
but he took the problem
and he solved it so one thing which we
have seen that
people can contribute to other problems
into a company
and when people like your boss or your
manager sees them
okay that you can take up a problem and
solve it and you are also concerned
about other problems
that means you are concerned about the
company to grow okay
that means that you are very very
motivated person
which wants to have a growth in the
company plus
wants to grow with the company as the
company grows okay
so jeff dean might have just ignored the
thing and that
had his coffee and bread back okay but
he did not
he worked over the weekend these two
three guys of this team worked for the
weekend that was not their project at
all
they were not thinking about appraisal
or getting a hike or whatever
getting promoted they are only working
so that the company doesn't create this
kind of problem so this is what
i was talking about uh it's about
learning opportunities
better learning opportunities can
present itself
anyway yeah and it's an interesting
other aspect of the t-shaped uh
worker is that
even if you're not doing a
cross-contribution as an
example that you gave from google um if
you understand how the other functions
in your company work then when it's your
time
to ask them for help or when it's
their time to ask you for help you will
understand
how to talk to them and what how to how
to
provide them the help or the information
that they need
or to ask them for the information you
need
in a way that they'll be able to
understand better and and work better
with you so
it it streamlines things
within a company when people have that
kind of cross-functional understanding
so it's a very useful thing
um what was the name of the book that
you mentioned just so i can put that
how everybody looks
and the problem-solving skills which
were like
focused in the people like the team
members
were very extraordinary because other
than the companies which have made it
big
there were very very simple problems
which they saw and they
gave rise to very very large let's say
very very simple is
um like the founder mentality that we
see
as entrepreneurs you want to see the
founder mentality in my
team members okay whoever team member is
inviting
they should lead the department as it is
their own company
it's kind of a micro company inside a
company and it comes from
the founder mentality if you have read
books of uh
kind of how airbnb has like scale and
how they have started
very interesting is the founder
mentality is doing everything on their
own
till do you have a technology to scale
it up so
in simple terms you have heard of the
line
like do things that do not scale
right a very clear example is airbnb
when they started off
uh they wanted to have uh
the listings on on their website and the
listings
had very draining photographs okay
so they took from the mobile phones at
that point of time the mobile phones
were not that good
right what did they do it drove away
visitors they do not want to visit a
home which has a
really program even even if you are
booking a hotel you want to have a very
good
view so it's like 360 degree view or a
very very
high definition photograph so you can
see how the bed looks how the
windows look like so the founders they
found this problem
and they read they took the camera on
lease they went out
into the neighborhood started taking
pictures with the
permission of the owners and they saw
the traffic come back to their website
and when they did that then they hired
like
a photography firm to do the program so
this is how they skill
so this is the founder mentality when we
see that in
a company and it's very very visible
they can think people who are applying
for their job
with the founder mentality is basically
how how
sincere is the candidate in doing the
assignments
have they done the assignments in full
have they asked very relevant questions
what is the quality of the assignment to
qualify
if they don't see you do your best work
at that point they're not going to see
it later
um i'm going to run one more poll before
we go to
questions and answers because this poll
um i think it addresses the
frustration some people might have
and open it up here while i
share
application
and what we're looking at is you know
what aspect of job hunting is the most
challenging for you is it
finding the job openings is it adjusting
to the world of online interviews
instead of face to face um
is it writing the resume
or you're one of the fortunate people
whose
main problem is i get the offers but
i want to be able to negotiate the
better terms
and
close the poll
and share the results
finding relevant job and
the second most popular was the resume
so um
how did um
final segment how does into hire help
candidates uh
resolve these frustrations so the first
major problem which we have asked is
like finding relevant job opportunities
finding job opportunities the candidates
like they want to apply to all the jobs
but they have to have selection of
certain jobs which are relevant for them
but how will you find relevant jobs you
cannot go through each and every job
post things like 10
000 things and then apply to each of
them which are relevant
but if you have a technology which can
suggest you
say 20 jobs where you will get maybe
a shortcut interview or maybe an
assignment drop
or maybe get a call from the recruiter
that will be very good for you right
so this is where we come in we
understand the candidate
over like on top of like not only the
resume
okay but also the preferences that
this guy wants to work in the startup
this guy has a very good
contribution over github or any other
tools which they use
very good uh behance profile so it's a
very good designer
okay so all these things come into play
uh this is the salary which they have
brought in the last job and the career
progression which they have got
this is the type of companies the guy
has worked for
this all comparing together we build a
personality a persona
a person of a candidate that helps us
to give them uh our suggestion of the
relevant job
openings which are there and they can
also apply to other job openings
where we give them a cumulative score on
basis of
past data we like we crunch millions of
data points
when we tell the candidate okay you have
a 99 for getting a
job interview with this company or you
have a 10 percent
chance of getting a job interview
because this company might not be
interested in
taking your interview or taking you to
the next level better you apply to this
set of companies but you have a 90
percent
chance so this suggestion is not
available in
traditional totals where people come in
and they
just do like tell just apply select all
and apply
and they do not get a relevant callback
because on the other hand also you have
to understand that recruiter is also
human so they will get like one lakh
emails in their
uh inbox and then they will be
like they will not process it basically
they will go for referrals
on any easy way out
let's move on to our questions and the
answers
and
got a question here from
vinay who says i have
16 and more years of experience in
different domains
in the last year i've been doing
business right now
if i did a data science and ai course
would that help me get a job
so that depends like if you have done
business
what is this like profile which you have
been in the last 16 years
okay and if you want to do a change in
profile right now
okay that will be the question which
will be answered but like it can be
asked by any recorder
which you do and uh really relations
course obviously
will help okay but we have to have
uh the passion for data science also
okay it's not that you do a question
people will comment for
job offers but you have to have a
pattern like for python or for coding or
to understand data so this also will be
evaluated
when you are getting into a job when you
get a job interview
the courses will take a backseat but you
will have to
prove your skills and your knowledge
also on the different
aspects of the job so if you are
applying for data engineer job or
database like engineering job you have
to show that
you are passionate about the difference
in you have solved problems
and you're ready to solve problems and
will you take that
that is one thing with courses are many
so
um we have a question from jesus
who asks how much are are
ats applicant tracking systems
a barrier are
yes are they something where
you know you just load in the keywords
to get seen and it doesn't really
get you to the relevant job or is
you know are there what are the
drawbacks for those types of
things and and how would you
differentiate insta higher from that
so abs is a application cutting system
uh like they load the candidate profiles
there
and they go for the round interviews
so this is the application system which
part but the thing is like
ats doesn't have that technology which
can identify
a candidate who is active who is very
relevant
versus the other candidate who might not
be active might not be relevant
or might be not at all relevant for the
job
okay so there instead comes in to show
that okay if you're heading for this
role
check out this uh like 500 candidates
who are actively looking out for a
change for relevant
who are also looking to like work in
similar problems and they have worked in
similar tolerance
we have seen them contributing in
certain similar problems before in their
career
and this is the candidate we should look
for ats basically
is that they do not have the technology
to
segregate the segregating the active and
the best candidate is not done by theirs
so that is the problem where if
it's like a black hole like if you put a
candle in it into an 80s or a regiment
like this it stays there until it has
been removed
so that is all so there is no nothing
like these are active candidates like i
have
said uh one million uh in my eight years
but i do not know like out of that
hundred thousand candidates might be
active i will never know so that is how
apc worked
um question from
what should a fresher do to get hired
so it depends on what kind of uh speech
do you have
pressures for purpose i think uh you
could always
experience a company uh when it is
being formed or in the formative ages
okay versus the enterprise because
if you enter into a company which is
like it will be your personal price
obviously but
you have seen that people when pressures
when they enter into this kind of
place where the company is growing and
you go with them you learn
to learn a lot of things fast okay and
generally it helps affects people your
experience it will definitely help you
in your career
and it will help you in getting a better
job or a better profile and whatever
so it might be that i'm doing a lot of
effort versus my friends at companies
who are not doing
anything and like who will bring less
work but yes
believe me this is worth it and you will
learn a lot of skills
you will learn a lot of um things which
they might not see
because you will do everything by your
own hand it's basically hands-on
experience which is very very rare
very very costly in the real world and
you get that
so as a pressure you should always go
for learning opportunities
and not think about basically the amount
of work or salaries
um i have a question
that asks does instahire
give advice to its candidates
on what skills gaps they might have and
what things they should be
studying to improve their
chances of getting hired yes we have a
recommended meeting which is
going live and in one month so we have
been fine during the recommended in
england
so right now the recommendation indian
will give you
uh according to your skills what are the
job people to apply for
okay and according to your skill or your
knowledge
what are the jobs you are i need to get
in like i
have very high chances of getting an
interview or a job offer
so then we will uh also have a
recommendation to
like tell them that this is the skill
gap which is which we have seen
and you can upgrade on this surface on
python on golan
or on on sales or on content
so we we will give you that kind of
recommendations which we are developing
so that takes a lot of millions of data
points to come into
and then service you know suggest you
the best kind of skills so that is what
we are doing
we have a just time for a few more
questions so i apologize to everybody
because
we've actually gotten dozens and dozens
of questions and
and don't have time to be able to
address all of them so again apologize
in advance but
here's an interesting question from
haruka who asks
i have a career gap right after
graduation because of my children
um and she's studying full stack java
development um what do you think
her chances are of being recruited
so the career gaps shouldn't matter
okay if you have a reason why
you have taken the career gap
i have taken a sabbatical i went through
i have been traveling or i've been
exploring
that is not a problem why because you
you cannot learn everything in a job
sitting in a cubicle working for clients
or working for yourself
you could go out sometime and see the
world
how it operates all the large companies
that you see
has been found by people who have gone
out seen the world
interacting with thousands of people
found out the problem
and tried to solve it so if you're not
going out you cannot see press problems
coming in
you cannot see like uh if you haven't
gone out
you might not see what how's the
glossary market operating
so you might not build a platform
where you can say uh get the best rates
for groceries
in your locality or any other locality
because you do not know what
how does this operate how is the pricing
fixed
okay how people bargain how people buy
so you will never get to know that yeah
so you will always be
confined in certain sets which is not
true
you should take uh like if you have
taken sabbatical
you should come up with an answer to
this i've taken this article i've
traveled the world i found out things
you can even
see that a company in india which was
acquired by baidu's
a white hat junior the person has taken
us a battle
has taken sabbatical went um traveled
the world
came back built whitehead junior and it
got attacked by 500
like 350 million dollars right
it made him a millionaire so like if
people
are doing it successfully there i think
will not be an issue to get a job
for that like like if i have a career
break or and this is a
valid career break so it is mandatory
for
mainly all in our organization to give a
mechanical need for paternity
that is not a problem
[Music]
let's see
okay um we'll do
just a couple more um jivan asks
if one is experienced in a particular
domain or stream and wants to switch
into a different one
for example ai and data science would
that person have to
start at the bottom with the
entry-level roles in that new field or
would
their experience in other fields account
for something
so yeah we have to see the overlapping
experience
okay if there is anything overlapping
with your previous experience
if there is no nothing overlapping you
have to start
oppressed because uh the other guy who
is hiring you
is taking a better so basically you have
to give the benefit of doubt that i can
perform
and i am capable and i am i can do that
so you have to always start from the
bottom
it's not like like starting from the
bottom you have to learn everything
bottom up because when you would be a
manager or you would be a gp you are
how to do that from zero to one so you
have to know zero to one you cannot go
from one to ten and
not from zero to one so that is the
basis
also found that sometimes
what counts from your other experience
is domain
knowledge in terms of if you
have been working in let us say the
banking industry for a long time
you know the industry very well and now
you want to switch
your skill sets within the same industry
your knowledge of the domain will help
you advance faster but you still have to
prove that your new skill set is is
valid
um we have a question
from a youtube viewer mayana who asks
what main point or main thing
does a recruiter see in
a resume other than the key skills
that will attract you know the the
interest of a of a hiring company
the main main thing the recruiter will
want to see is basically how your
previous experiences have been
and what have you achieved in the
previous experiences if i am building
a e-commerce platform and i am a
recruiter or i am the founder i am
hiding from my team
and i want to build a very good ui from
for my app with promisa i will always
find a person who has built very good
apps with very good urls right
so this is basically i will see what
fast experience we have
and skills will not be
like if you have since yes it's very
good if you do not have skills
but you know how to do that maybe you
have aptitude so that i will hire you
okay and and expect you to use this
attitude to learn more skills
and be better at your job or else i will
see people who have proven experience
who have student themselves so if i'm
hiring a senior i'm having a vp of sales
okay i will have people who have done
million dollar things in my
in the last company because i want to do
a million dollar tv in my company
i won't hire a person who has done 10
000
dollar deals because they will know ten
thousand to the fifty thousand dollar
bill
but they will not know the ropes of
doing a one to ten million dollar books
but i want to do that you i will hire
that kind of person
it's not just the skills with how you've
been applying them yeah yes
um and the last question um again
i apologize to everyone who's questions
we were not able to take
um but the last question is from rico
and we'll exit on this one which is what
changes in recruiting do you expect to
see in the coming future
so uh a lot of changes uh are being
consistently invited by two people
so a lot of emphasis on assignments
a lot of emphasis on the uh how how the
candidate will
challenge because maybe the onboarding
might be remote
the person might be working remotely
okay
accountability how you test
accountability okay
cultural fit is very very important
right now because
people when when they build uh companies
they are always into culture the first
thing which they build is culture
and this culture helps into the uh
learning abilities of a candidate when
they join him suppose i build a very
very
motivating culture we will be motivated
to learn new skills and apply
so that the company goes further
companies work from 100
so this is the first thing which they
see secondly the use of
tools have been increased more and more
technology has been
introduced into the equipment space the
hiring things will be mostly
uh more remote higher or hybrid
what kind of workspaces will be there
and in doing the remote
the major problem is engagement
candidate engagement so the scanning
engagement will
take a very very steep turnaround so
before that you came into office you had
birthday parties you had
all this stuff and you met your teams at
the end they can have beer parties
now you don't have that right so this is
the engagement so this is the
recruitment trend which is going in
companies will invest more in employer
branding
they will invest more in candid better
experience
okay and uh onboarding and also perks
will go up
so yes motivating and all the skills
will
be one of the major factors that
companies will look into candidates
excellent
um so before we end the webinar i'm
going to ask
one question one more
question of the audience which is
um we
you you talked about the t-shaped
um employee the the person who has
broad skills as well as deep skills in a
particular area
and so i'm asking
what areas are each of you out there
most interested in learning um either to
deepen your skills in a particular area
or to broaden them
to multiple areas and when do you think
you'd
want to start doing that
[Music]
and i noticed we've got a number of
questions about data science and ai and
machine learning so
that seems to be a popular
area of study but
again broadening is an important
factor so let me um
see what the poll results tell us
so business and project management and
data science are the two
top categories that people are
interested in
and about a third of you are interested
in
doing that right away so
commend you on that and that's a now is
always a good time to start
and with that i'm going to
thank sarbrajit i'm putting up his
linkedin connection information
for people who want to follow up um but
i do want to thank you
for being here today and sharing your
your insights with us and being so
generous with your time
thank you so much thank you so much guys
for tuning in
for following me take care have fun
peace thank you guys and i'm going to
make a couple of
last announcements
we have been dropping in the chat window
information about the skill up program
from simply learn
which is a free program and
it allows you to do the self study parts
of
our education programs
training programs through video content
over a thousand hours of video content
actually over 600 skills now and
you will on completing each of the
self-study courses
you do actually receive a certificate of
completion
that shows that you've undertaken that
so find out more about that by clicking
the link that i've just put into the
chat
um and the next thing
is for those of you interested
in digital marketing or for those of you
who
have friends interested in digital
marketing um
we are doing a digital marketing master
class as our next webinar
that will be one week from today
and it will be looking at
what goes on in the google black box
google is very
jealous about its the privacy of its
proprietary
and methods so
this will give you a little bit of
insight
from outside looking in on what happens
in the google black box
brad gettys our ppc charity simply learn
pay-per-click digital advertising um
is the expert will present that and
again i've dropped the
link into the chat so you'll be able to
register for that class and that
concludes the webinar
uh please keep in touch with us at our
social media
handles at simply learn on facebook
twitter
look for simply learn on that then and
we look forward
to seeing you at future simply learn
webinars
thank you all for being here and thank
you for sticking with us
thank you so goodbye much thank you
thank you sport thank you bye
you